hi there Steve Compton here today I want
to talk about the power of reading and
I'm gonna explain why I'm on this
subject first of all today is December
the 10th here in Vancouver a week from
now I will be in Fez Morocco
I am hoping now I know they don't speak
the same Arabic as I've been learning
they speak Moroccan Arabic and I'm not
gonna bother trying to learn it because
I'm only gonna be there six days five
days I'm going to see if I can find you
know taxi drivers or city guides who
speak Fattah who speak Standard Arabic
so that I can get a you know guide of
the city or a tour to some of the
outskirts or nearby sites with someone
who speaks Standard Arabic in any way in
any case I'm going to look for people or
I might just find a tutor I want to
speak Arabic I'm gonna read Arabic and
but of course I'm gonna be surrounded by
people who speak quite a different form
of Arabic but it will be a comfort to me
that I'll be able to read at least to
some extent and I am I definitely feel
that I'm turning the corner in my
ability to read Arabic and I think
reading is key is so important in
language learning stephen krashen always
talks about extensive voluntary reading
extensive reading I remember I was at a
presentation where teachers were talking
about story listening as a strategy in
the classroom and the goal was to get
the students motivated so that they
would read reading enables us to consume
so much of the language inexpensively by
borrowing books at the library or
whatever or finding stuff on the
internet reading is a phenomenal way of
learning languages reading is a
phenomenal way of learning anything and
if we look back in time of course before
there was writing all we had was
storytelling and storytelling
tellers in many cultures would simply
repeat the stories to the next
generation and the next generation and
that's how we have you know Homer's
Ulysses and the Iliad and so forth and
so on
Odyssey this you know the Odyssey and
Nealon and stuff like that and similar
traditions in other cultures in
Southeast Asia and elsewhere so writing
which began I think more to record
stocks of grain it was more like an
accounting thing and that was true in in
Mesopotamia I was even true when I was
in in Cusco and I learned about the the
original sort of writing system of the
Incas which was knots in a rope or
things of that nature so it was you know
writing was the means of recording
things that otherwise would have had to
be maintained orally so if people had
invented the mp3 technology before
writing maybe we would never have moved
towards ready
I don't know but writing is a way of
recording speech and so when we are
reading we are ingesting words we are
ingesting hopefully interesting content
and certainly there's a lot of work now
being done to improve literacy in even
in developed countries because a
significant percentage of the population
in all developed countries doesn't read
very well and the better people read the
better they do economically academically
high percentage of people in prison have
low literacy their studies that show
that maybe a quarter of kids start
school with a sort of reading gap that
they will never ever catch up on because
their parents didn't read to them or
because the parents didn't use a wide
vocabulary at home or for any number of
reasons and then there's the problem of
dyslexia and someone commented to link
this week and they said I have never
been able to read a book because I have
severe dyslexia but using link and on I
think probably on a mobile device and
using the sentence mode so that he
breaks down text into one sentence at a
time and being able to hear the words
text-to-speech any word that he has
trouble reading he
has read five Russian novels in one year
this learner of ours and I thought to
myself you know it's true that link
helps you read because for me reading
Arabic is a bit like being dyslexic
because first of all I mean to some
extent in English you can't necessarily
tell how a word is pronounced just by
the way it's spelled but that's much
more of a problem in Arabic where in
many of the texts of owls are not
indicated so you just have consonants
and you don't know they're it's an O or
an e in between the consonants and plus
I'm still getting used to these letters
and I still confuse some of them and so
I might be like the dyslexic reader but
I am able to read by looking words up by
clicking on the text to speech and then
hearing the natural voice and slowly
slowly slowly this improves my ability
to read to the point where now I can
pick up a paper book which I did for
this I had bought this harems method
Express for learning Arabic and the font
is so small I couldn't read it to save
my life but now I can read it and I
think that the same is true could be
true for people who suffer from dyslexia
at any rate I would like to find out one
day if what we do at link and the
functionality there would be helpful to
people who are dyslexic or people who
have trouble with literacy but in any
case reading is probably the most
efficient least cost way of acquiring
information and and I should say too
that you know reading is like is like
listening without the audio because very
often especially if it's a foreign
language we are sub vocalizing as we are
reading and conversely when I hear a
word I the image that I have is the
written word so if it were English and I
and I think of the word read I don't see
the color red
see re D and when I listen to Arabic now
more and more I am able to visualize the
written word that corresponds to that
spoken word if I know the word if I
don't know the word I can't do that so I
have that kind of a relationship to Arab
words I have to know them I can't
necessarily read an unknown word and
pronounce it correctly all by myself but
I am able to connect the sounds of
certain words to the way those words are
written so all I'm getting at in all of
this is people think they're gonna talk
the way to fluency as you know I'm not a
big fan of that I think that you read
and listen your way to a significant
potential level in a language and then
you go out and expose yourself to as
much opportunity to speak as possible
but you are at least starting from a
position of strength because you have
this vocabulary this familiarity with
the language this ability to connect
written words to spoken words and so
forth so that your speaking skills grow
quite quickly again my previous video
was about this a Kiowa in Japan and
someone said well you know in Japan they
need more practice at speaking because
they can all read I have not found that
to be the case when I speak to people
who claim that they can read well
whether they be from Asia or anywhere
and then I say well have you read any
novels recently in English do you read
what do you read besides the odd
newspaper article they don't read very
much so when I'm talking about reading
I'm talking about for example my
statistics and Russian write read three
million words like lots of reading
reading is a powerful way and an
inexpensive way to improve your language
skills and it's also an extremely
important skill for life so that's kind
of what I was all inspired by this
fellow who claimed that he had heavy
dyslexia and had been able to read five
Russian novels in a year and of course
he's a learner of Russian so and using
the kind of functionality that we have
at Lincoln that others may also have
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]